الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انه رئيس
لجميع الاتراك بصرف النظر عن انتماءاتهم
السياسيه ودع المعارضته الى التصالح مع
الاراده الوطنيه وفي كلمه لدى ادائه
اليمين الدستوريه رئيسا لتركيا لولايه
ثالثه تعهد اردوغان بالعمل على حمايه
الدوله واستقلالها
والتاريخ ان اعمل بكل قوه على حمايه وجود
الدوله واستقلالها وان اعمل على الوحده
التامه للامه والوطن وسياده غير المشروطه
للشعب وان ابقى ملتزما بالدستور وسياده
القانون والديمقراطيه وبمبادئ واصلاحات
اتاتورك ومبدا الجمهوريه العلمانيه والا
اتخلى عن مبدا امن ورفاهيه الشعب وتمتع كل
شخص بالحريات الاساسيه وحقوق الانسان في
اطار مفهوم العداله وتضامن الشعبي وان
احافظ على شانه وشرف الجمهوريه التركيه
وان اعلي شانها وان اعمل بكل ما اوتيت من
قوه للايفاء بمهام وظيفته بحياديه